vous êtes un des plus grands danseurs
chorégraphes au monde c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est un london times ok
alors commençons par parler de votre
nouveau spectacle crypte où le mariage
de danse classique et la danse
contemporaine kryptos à un des projets
que j'ai commencé avec ma compagnie côté
danse puis c'est un projet que on a
commencé un peu avec l'idée de explorer
un conte de fées moderne
c'est dans le sens que j'ai toujours
aimé l'idée du mythe grec ou du conte de
fée pour la danse je pense que des
grosses d'idées comme ça exagéré avec
des thèmes qui nous donne un petit peu
d'aidé comme des façons de trouver comme
l'extrême de lui même de l'humanité je
trouvais que ça faisait quelque chose de
bien tu es à explorer mais vous avez
chaussez vos premiers chaussons à l'âge
de trois ans est ce que vous vous
souvenez du moment vous êtes tombé en
amour avec la danse
je dois j'aimerais ça comme dit oui et
je me souviens du moment mais j'ai
tellement toujours danser
je me souvienne plusieurs petits moments
par exemple ces petits moments où ce que
je me disais oui ça c'est quelque chose
que je peux pas vivre sans sommet mais
toutes ces moments là la plupart de ces
moments là sont en studio dès leur jeune
âge j'aimais ça être en studio jamais ce
travail et j'aimais se perfectionner mes
affaires je m'associe la communication
avec le mouvement si j'ai toujours aimé
être avec mes amis être avec mes
collaborateurs être proche de ça
rapproche les gens dans une façon qui
est comme qui qui est tellement plus
tellement plus je pense unique qu'avec
le jour de vos quarante ans vous avez bu
un café avec votre idole michael
baryshnikov là pourquoi c'est votre
idole c'est une personne qui est
tellement eu d'influencé a changé ma vie
parce que michaël boch ninkov c'est
quelqu'un qui a dansé dans white knight
c'est un film ce qui est moi j'étais un
petit peu du lac saint jean puis quand
même au lac-saint-jean n'y avait pas
vraiment de compagnie dans ce qu'ils
faisaient des suspects réglable mai mais
le film white nights il venait de sortir
et puis c'est sûr j'avais écouté sa
télévision puis ça vraiment ça me
donnait le goût de travailler justement
avec avec lui mais aussi de devenir
danseur est aussi avait il y avait dans
l'est dans la première scène du film il
y avait une scène qui s'appelait le
jeune homme et la mort c'est un ballet
de roland petit
et puis je me suis dit je me suis donné
comme but que jal est dentiste balle
elle est travaillée avec roland petit et
oui évidemment je me suis je me suis
retour retrouver à la scala
20 bons 25 ans plus tard travailler
personnellement avec roland petit
alors je pense que ça fait une belle
boucle à montréal vous avez douze mille
abonnés sur instagram et vous partagez
votre vie avec la première danseuse it
works 2 du ballet national du canada
vous connaissez depuis très longtemps et
comment ça se passe justement à la
maison alors que tous les deux vous êtes
danseur avec tous les sacrifices que ça
implique
c'est un genre de négociations je pense
c'est toujours c'est toujours quelque
chose qui on a deux enfants au site on a
deux enfants puis on est toujours dans
ces ensembles fait une belle
collaboration ça prend une équipe on a
appris à se connaître bien avant qu'on
est ensemble on a dansé ensemble pour un
monde en plein d'années avant qu'on soit
en couple on a lancé notre premier roméo
juliette ensemble quand on avait 18 et
19 ans
fait qu'on se connaît très bien fait qu
il y avait un élément que de complicité
vraiment qui qui va bien dans ce il ya
aussi comme une compréhension
on se comprend on comprend aussi que ça
prend un sacrifice s'apprend faut être
fou un peu pour faire notre carrière
fait que je pense qu'on est toutes les
deux on vit dans le même monde sait qu
on se comprend
vous avez dansé pour le théâtre bolchoï
il ya quelques semaines d'été à toronto
pour un spectacle bénéfice pour venir en
aide à l'ukraine beaucoup de danseurs
russes ukrainiens comment vous vivez ce
conflit là qu'ils doivent tous ses
intérieurs mais je pense que c'est une
situation qui me brise le coeur parce
que j'ai beaucoup d'amis j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui sont prisonniers de la
situation des amis qui veulent juste
avoir une belle carrière en danse puis
cd coûte les danseurs en russie le chili
danseurs qui sont ukrainien aussi qui
vivent en russie certaines des meilleurs
danseurs de l'histoire de tous les temps
passés des danseurs qui ont des
carrières incroyable puis tout d'un coup
jour au lendemain c'est tout et les
vaporetti leur carrière est finie d'un
sens puis en a certains aussi qu'ils
sont partis de la russie alors on peut
germer revenir à la maison on se
retrouve dans une situation comme comme
durant white knight dans le sens durant
le temps de soviet union gd plusieurs
amis dont des amis avec lequel j'ai fait
les rois de la danse que j'ai eu des
tournées mondiales avec eux fait des
amis très proches qu'ils m'envoient des
messages me disent que tu peux trouver
des dunes trouver un travail a osé au
canada tout ça pour dire que en ce
moment il n'y a pas vraiment de place on
finit une pandémie mondiale aussi fait
que je pense que plusieurs compagnies
qui aussi malheureusement ne peuvent pas
prendre de nouveau de nous de nouveaux
danseurs les meilleurs danseurs sont
nécessairement je pense français
alors la formation aux québécois aux
québécois
guillaume côté merci pour cette entrevue
inspirant très grand plaisir